here we go first shot of the day this
guy over here is going to direct just
for one day and then we're going to see
how he goes experience exciting
love and thunder
[Applause]
[Music]
it's just so loud and in your face and
flamboyant
it's always really fun working with
haike
it's been an absolute disaster but
that's just the way it is on my films
taika it's like a big kid sort of genius
child this this imagination is second to
none
tyke is a very bloody original filmmaker
he's mind-blowingly talented
this movie is just going to double down
on ragnarok how vibrant the worlds are
tiger wanted to have fun tell a big
story
[Music]
but also showcase this emotion and this
heart that taika can do
i think taika is really good at
reflecting the way life can be
dark and comedic all at once though we
wanted to make a crazy space invention
but also something that's emotional it
means something you ever feel lost look
into the eyes of the people that you
love
my uh sensing feelings
well you're right
taika brought such a new energy
not just to the marvel universe but to
this franchise
it certainly has everything comedy
drama
action
there's never a dull moment
when we first came up with love and
thunder we thought yeah the fans will
really freak out about this i love you
all and that is a wrap
[Music]
you